welcome to this video this is a back to
back game
I just don't played against the sky and
lost
now I play McGann all right so we got
them chigorin yeah a Goran type of
position and somehow I feel I had played
this against him before interesting
really f5 that that looks very weakening
okay
23 maybe
you know the Sun pins the Sun pins this
night should be okay really I don't
really believe in the capture yeah this
would give me good control over you form
a Jetta okay
what force is night back
hmm but this looks nice for wider
doesn't it b7 hangs yeah well I gives us
check and play 95 huh
business should be quite good oh it's
them a better movie ok the check is a
check did you close the door sorry for
that but the the dryer was a bit too for
for clothes the clothes dryer this is
the right name laundry dryer something
like that was just a bit bit too loud
ok let's see yeah this f3 a month f3 96
that looks really really not very
harmonious but don't don't see a direct
refutation
there's also c4 of course yeah maybe I
should
should I can see we can probably take
and here's Queen f5 at the end it's not
hmm I'm not sure not sure many many
possible moves okay I'll do that
but I'm not totally sure what's the best
if three was also interesting castles
was interesting yeah okay so here more
than one way to go I thought actually
that this might be okay
if he takes I wonder what what is
thinking about maybe five Queen a six is
just just not working um keeper ship
yeah I was originally planning to take
on e4 take on c4 but Bishop c4 is is
quite interesting okay let's gamble with
that I haven't calculated this to the
end but should be five it's very
interesting after b5 and if he's not
playing b5 I just have an overwhelming
position the bishop preventing castling
and two bishops form to e5 so it's
basically a yeah if you cannot play b5
then if he I mean he must do that
otherwise black is such that Egypt is so
worse that I don't think it is a
playable position anymore
yeah b5 takes takes Queen takes Queen d7
Queen to to the moon the King King there
is Knight Queen takes f5 the Queen d7
thought Queen e5 checkers interesting
intending rook c7 okay so he's he's
amazing he's not playing d5 I mean maybe
it it wasn't really great but this
position just was just very bad for
black more than one way Bishop should be
six was also strong okay I can now win
here at least a pawn with a good
position and I'll do that it's probably
even even more than a pawn check check
I'm getting b7
ya know I can take and queen takes all
with the tempo what rook takes what I'm
trying to say so now I can just castle
and keep my advantages rook c5 is the
next move coming
yeah that's that's enough yeah I think
he unless b5 wasn't working technically
he needed to do that I didn't see a
flat-out win but flat-out win with the
the the sacrifice on b5 but if there
wasn't anything he needed to play it
just the only move to at least get some
material for your for your suffering
they're now blankets just is a pawn down
played bad King weakness on c6 the only
hope is that I blend of the Queen
somehow but it's not it does not really
look very likely to happen let's just
make some some space yeah
and now I can just drop back getting the
Queen to c2 it's the easiest maybe
already I could have I could have gone
to to to have seven as well yeah but
okay there's only one point in a chess
game to win
knocking a form I should have taken it
from it's really easier
yeah behind behind the pawn check mmm
let's just briefly consider what is
easiest if I go over to be two-time has
got to cut the king there so not not
really necessary check black resigns
yeah the key position was wait let's
just briefly check this he took here and
I took here so you takes and yep here my
original intention was to take here and
here and I thought that white should be
a somewhat better yeah but that's not so
clear because of Queen a5 and then while
we were there I was considering if this
is a move I mean it is a gamble
I didn't calculate b5 really just
thought okay this should be a should be
interesting and the problem is if he
does not play it it's really just too
bad the two bishops I prevent castling
all week yeah I think after 96 this is
probably losing there should be six is
the computer move right this is not much
worse no it's plus three it's just too
too bad strategically so we need to
check this if this is winning or
whatever it is check okay yeah well
what's clear is this is not on check
yeah this you won't survive very
important is that the bishop here is
supporting the entry of the rook this
was this ad seen that this is an
additional oops sorry this is an
additional attacking muti so here he
basically has to play
27 and now my my brief calculation was
Queen g5 check Queen e7 and then from
here this was my idea
I can I can play many moves Queen f5
even taking a truck c7 she's not not
totally crazy yeah because I have I
simply have an initiative even with the
Queen's off but that's not really a
convincing maybe Queenie 5:27 Queen f5
this looks scary but it's not clear that
it helps him much yum the computer gives
white a slight advantage here
interesting year after Knight f6 j f5
and queen g6 yeah whatever this is it's
not winning for white I mean it's just
interesting and was certainly worth
trying yeah and this this is just not
something that black and sabasha
this was just was just one way one way
to convert it yeah he needed to play b5
trying to try to check if this was
really really working ok thanks for
watching